hey and welcome to conan o'brien needs a
friend i just looked up
and read off a monitor that says the
name of our podcast did you forget i'm
aware that i just said hey and welcome
to and i looked up and read it off the
monitor we should put something out
there
yeah welcome to matt and sona get a
raise yeah it's like an anchorman where
he'll he'll read whatever he reads
whatever what does he say [ __ ] you
san diego
oh wait no i think it's go [ __ ] yourself
yeah
go [ __ ] yourself i just don't want to
misquote anchorman anyway i just i don't
know why i did that i looked up i know
that this is called conor o'brien needs
a friend but i looked up and i do i
really do just don't take that monitor
away
that's how relaxed i am let's look at it
that way yeah that's how relaxed and in
the moment and sonia you'll attest i
don't i'm not a relaxed person most of
the time you're not why
i just just stop what do you mean stop
what
stop do it stop doing that i think just
chill
if i could i would yeah you know that
but you know you've really worked on
yourself a lot you're a very different
person than when i first started working
for you i will say that i've seen this
11 or 12 years ago 13. wow it's 2009.
okay that's right that's working for you
and what was the difference what was i
like then i think you were wound up
really tight it was also when you were
about to move to los angeles there was a
lot going on and you were very like you
know
[Music]
so nervous i i have no idea i don't
think i walked around going on no no you
weren't but you could tell there was
like just this weight on you and you
were like
you know there was a lot going on and
now you seem a lot more
i'm happier i'm a lot happier than i was
that's nice yeah i mean we've been lucky
that uh
i think that the tbs show was so much
fun to do yeah and really kind of a
joyous experience and and those were
great people to work with and then this
thing has been been just tripping
my wife she has a relative who if
something good happens to you they say
well you landed your ass in butter oh
that's awesome yeah oh you landed your
ass in butter but that's how it feels
getting to do this
i just want all the people listening to
picture my bony
pale irish ass yeah that ain't getting
any younger um
being dipped into sort of liquid i'm
going to say melting butter it's very
soft mushy butter like is it opaque or
is it kind of transparent like movie
theater pop it's sort of starting to get
translucent around the edges oh cool and
it's also very hot so as i'm being
lowered into it my i start screaming
because it's burning my ass
congratulations you did so i want to say
i really did not good with this podcast
i landed my ass in my bare ass in
scalding hot butter you did it literally
you heard that expression and you just
tried it literally yeah i did i thought
that must be great so i had myself i had
a winch put in the kitchen
and i had myself lowered
it's a i'm sorry what's a winch a winch
i had to tell it's like a pulley system
like on the front of a jeep if you want
to pull a jeep out of a mud you it's
like a cable that will
spool it has a motor and so i had myself
i bought i actually stole it off of a
jeep that i saw a parking lot yeah and i
had it attached
uh to the ceiling in my kitchen and i
had myself lowered
and into this vat of butter the guy in
the parking lot was where are you going
with that wedge
so you're not going to dig you dip your
ass in butter are you
and i said uh i don't no i wouldn't do
that
don't do it if you do make sure it's
room temperature butter
anywho anything i'm saying you put your
ass in butter i'll get us back on track
which is and i'm sure there'll be some
edits here um
yeah we were very fortunate i was very
fortunate to to uh land this silly gig
it's really fun and uh
you know i'm enjoying myself so i think
i'm a happier chappie yeah than i was 13
years ago good yeah and also i don't see
you like every day sona you know what i
mean you've got your kids and stuff we
see each other a lot
it doesn't feel that way it doesn't no
no i think we do i used to see you
constantly i would see you all day long
and then if i was doing a show at night
you'd come on that if i if i toured you
came on the tour yeah you were
omnipresent in my life right all the
time now
it feels like yeah i see you when we do
this
and uh i see you here and there that's
true but you seem happier i am so much
happier i don't know what happened for
the last 11 months i'm just kidding i'm
kidding come on
to the end we're friends forever yeah
all right let's get on with this it
smells like ass butter in here that's
better jesus i'm literally
try it folks
dip your ass in very hot butter
take it from me it's the most central
experience you'll ever have
what if today's guest was like malala
[Laughter]
and right now you just look out and you
see that they're walking away
i've always wanted to
have a really stupid segment up front
and then look over and see
through the window that the guest is
gone
and i'd be like wait a minute who was it
it was uh you know
civil rights activists like a really
serious good person doing good work and
they just heard me dipping my ass in
butter they're like i'm gonna go you've
done in the past when we've had like
hillary clinton or you know barack obama
you're like guys we have to keep this
intro very professional and then it
always always devolves obama tried to
leave remember
yeah he tried to go and the door he
couldn't get the door we don't remember
because we weren't invited we weren't we
weren't at that point oh right right
they yeah the secret service looked into
your background
but they somehow approved ass better guy
oh
trust me
sony you actually have a rap sheet so i
don't no i don't that's why i've gotten
away with so much because i i don't no
one's ever
yes yes i know every no i'm not a
pickpocket sticky fingers that would be
really cool if i knew that you stole a
scrunchie right
what did you steal a scrunchie oh a monk
a lot of us yeah you go to forever 21
and steal stuff no not well that's why
you didn't get to meet obama because you
are a thief it's i don't have a record
that's why i kept saying
there's having a record and then there's
what the secret service can find out
they knew exactly what you had done and
they knew that you could not be around
the president they presented you with
the scrunchies
obama was like where's the scrunchie
thief
scratchy thief here
where the thief this is the pickpocket
no she couldn't be here all right okay
secret service never
oh come on that's jackie mason slash
barack obama it's both if you want
my guest today hey if you want
impressions this is not the place to
tune in okay
today oh that was obama